Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt. Mein Name ist Tim Britlav und äh I have joint Forces again mit Pabel, hallo Pabel.
Denn heute ist natürlich Corona Wiki angesagt und äh wie es hier so die Sitte ist, wollen wir ein wenig äh gucken, was sich denn so getan hat
in der Corona Zahlenwelt und äh was es sonst vielleicht noch Interessantes zu beobachten und zu kommentieren gibt.
Wissen da eigentlich dein, dein äh Lokdownlight bisher verlaufen? Pavel.
Ja ja wie gesagt weitgehend unverändert, ne das stimmt eigentlich nicht. Ich halte mich jetzt irgendwie noch wirklich weitgehend komplett von irgendwie.
Mehreren Menschen äh entfernt äh und äh ja habe mich glaube ich irgendwie außer mit der Familie mit zwei Leuten getroffen jetzt,
seit dem Lokdown light nacheinander und ja.
Versuche das Einkaufen zu minimieren und ja es gibt ziemlich viele Serien habe ich festgestellt so äh die man gucken kann, die von denen ich noch nie gehört habe und.
Das stimmt. Da habe ich auch schon das ein oder andere ausgegraben, obwohl ich gar nicht so ein Serienchruger bin, aber was soll man jetzt auch anderes machen, ne? Na ja, aber es gibt ja noch Wahl in USA, da werden wir heute nicht drüber reden.
Na ja, ach äh wer sieht sie jetzt aber gerade eigentlich äh ganz gut aus so.
Ja, aber ich glaube, der Spaß, der wird sich noch ein paar Wochen halten, also da.
Ja, es wird noch wird noch werden, noch Aufreger kommen, aber im Moment äh sieht es so aus, als wenn der Worst Case zumindest nicht eingetreten ist.
Das äh kann sein, dann gucken wir mal, äh wie wir so bei dem Worst Case stehen, der uns so Corona technisch umgibt.
Äh ich habe auch nochmal das Haus verlassen und habe ein äh nettes Angebot angenommen und bin hier in Berlin in so ein Forschungsinstitut reingelatscht
mal viel Zeit damit verbringen konnte, viele Fragen zu Fragen und selber einen PCR-Test durchgeführt habe.
Das war mal interessant. Ja und ähm dazu muss ich gleich mal anmerken, also ich habe kein.
Corona, Virus, saß, Kopf zwei.
Per C äh PCR-Test gemacht, sondern ich habe einfach nur was heißt nur, aber ich habe sozusagen mal.
Nachvollzogen und zwar richtig Schritt für Schritt mit selber pipetieren und all diesen ganzen Klimpert, der da so dranhängt und diesen Gerät, was man da so zum Einsatz bringt und habe äh ja, mal DNA in einer Probe,
nachgewiesen, so eben mit diesem Prozess, äh, den man so macht. Und das, das war schon wirklich extrem lehrreich, um auch mal konkret nachzuvollziehen, was jetzt so Larchskale eigentlich alles so ausgerollt wird, um eben.
Erzählst du da nachher noch ein bisschen zu oder.
Jetzt auch gerne. Ja, das können wir ja vielleicht mal vorneweg machen.
Also selber habe ich das jetzt noch nicht gemacht, aber ich habe mir halt auch natürlich YouTube-Videos angeguckt äh so wie.
Im Prinzip geht und wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe ist so der zentrale Prozess eigentlich.
Dass die Probe dann im Prinzip in den Ofen kommt, der dann so ziemlich äh ja in Stufen jeweils die Temperatur rauf und runter fährt für eine bestimmte Zeit. Ist das richtig? Gab's da sowas?
Sowas gab's da, genau. Ofen ist vielleicht nicht die richtige Bezeichnung, ist halt so ein Gerät, wo die Proben reingesteckt werden und das Gerät ist halt in der Lage, diese Proben innerhalb kürzester Zeit auf bestimmte Temperaturen hoch und wieder runterzufahren
um eben Temperatur induziert bestimmte Reaktionen hervorzurufen und die dann auch regelmäßig zu wiederholen. Um halt diesen eigentlichen,
Prozess, also PCR steht ja für Polymerase, äh Chan Reaction, also Polymerase, Kettenreaktionen,
das Ziel der ganzen Geschichte ist, dass man halt kein Teil der DNA seliktiert.
Und den dann immer wieder kopiert und dann so exponentiell sich verbreiten lässt dadurch.
Das heißt, diese Maschinen sind quasi, wenn so drauf programmiert äh alles erstmal so in Betrieb zu bringen,
und dann, wenn eben dieser Ausschnitt dann äh gefunden ist, den immer wieder zu äh vervielfältigen. Und äh in meinem Fall war dieses Gerät so eine anderthalb Stunde damit beschäftigt.
Das ist auch so ein üblicher Zeitraum, so der so äh durchgeführt wird. Den Corona Test ist es.
Ein, wenn ich's richtig erinnere, so ein dreistufiger Test, das heißt, da muss so eine Phase im Prinzip dreimal abgeschlossen werden, auch wenn's da.
Timierungspotential gibt, die so zu parallelisieren äh et cetera, aber so oder so, um wirklich zu Nachweis zu machen mit dieser Methode
dauert es eben eine gewisse Zeit, weil du musst halt einfach diese biologischen Prozesse ablaufen lassen und die brauchen halt ihre Zeit.
Und das war dann auch eine, wo dann die Probe Floris Zint geworden ist oder wie äh sieht es aus fielen da dann hinterher eine Kurve raus oder eine Zahl.
Ähm nee, da gab's dann was zum Angucken. Also ihr könnt da jetzt so viel zu erzählen, ich muss äh schauen, dass ich das jetzt äh praktisch zusammengefasst bekomme,
Also zunächst einmal muss man halt sich quasi diese Probe zusammenpubetieren. Dann können halt so verschiedene Materialien dazu, die einfach erforderlich sind, um diesen Prozess ablaufen zu lassen.
Letztlich ist es ja ein Nachweis auf den A, also du hast halt diese.
Diese Doppelheliks, also aus zwei Strängen, wo dann eben diese ganzen Geninformationen drankleben als äh Basenpaare, die ähm muss halt erstmal so aufgerissen werden, dass es dann so dieser initiale.
Temperaturanstieg, damit trennen die sich dann so auf und du gibst halt so Stoffe dazu, die nennen sich Primer, die dann eben an diesen bestimmten Punkten einfach schon mal andocken.
Damit für diesen Wirkstoff, der diesen Kopiervorgang, also diese eigentliche Polymerase, der dann diesen Kopiervorgang macht, quasi so die Stelle markiert, wo es anfangen soll.
Mhm. Und das Ende vermutlich auch.
Ja, also du machst quasi einen Marker auf jedem Strang,
setzt quasi an beiden einen Anfang der zusammengenommen Anfang und Ende darstellt, aber so für die Polymerase ist das so quasi dass so zwei Anfänge.
Und durch diesen Prozess reduziert sich das relativ schnell wirklich nur auf diesen einen Strang, der dich interessiert.
Und dann kommt halt diese Wiederholung eines Prozesses, wo dann eben immer wieder Temperatur hoch und runter geht und dadurch äh wird dann immer wieder diese Duplikation angesteuert. Und am Ende hast du dann halt in dieser Suppe,
entweder eine extrem große Menge dieses Genstranks,
oder eben keine, je nachdem, ob die Ursprungs-DNA da überhaupt drin war, weil wenn da gar keine drin war, dann konnte da auch nichts andocken, dann kann, wenn er nichts andockt, kann er auch nichts multipliziert werden.
Und woran konntest du die jetzt erkennen.
Ja, dann am Ende nimmst du das dann raus und ähm.
Du nimmst dann so eine Art Gelbet. Also das ist dann quasi nochmal so eine gelierte Flüssigkeit.
Okay, hm, hm.
Das gehe muss man auch selber anrühren und wird dann so eine Viertelstunde irgendwie fest und spannendste so quasi in so zwei in so ein Blog ein,
an der einen Stelle wird nochmal so ein Kamm reingesteckt, der quasi in diesem Gel dann dafür sorgt, dass da so Taschen entstehen, also wenn das Gel dann fest ist, ziehst du diesen Kamm wieder raus und dann hast du dann so vier, fünf, sechs, sieben,
Taschen.
Das Ganze wird nochmal mit so einer Flüssigkeit übergossen und dann kannst du halt in diese Taschen diese Probe reintun, also nimmst die eigentliche Probe, die du jetzt durch diesen Apparat gejagt hast.
Pipetierst du dann eben in diese eine Tasche äh rein und dann,
hast du quasi immer noch das die Vergleichsprobe, das heißt du mischst eigentlich das, was du anmischt zweimal an, nur einmal gibst du die Ursprungs-DNA mit rein und einmal lässt du sie weg, einfach um so einen Vergleich zu haben.
Um zu sehen, ob der Prozess an sich funktioniert hat. Das kommt dann halt in eine zweite äh Tasche rein und was du letzten Endes mit diesem Gel.
Dann machst es, du legst einen Strom an. Das heißt, da wird dann so ungefähr achtzig Volt Strom angelegt.
Und das führt dann dazu, dass ähm,
dieses DNA-Material durch dieses Gel durchgedrückt wird. Das breitet sich also wirklich quasi geographisch aus.
Und zu diesem Zeitpunkt geht's eigentlich nur noch da drum rauszukriegen ähm.
Welche Länge hat dieser DNA-Strang, den du da erwischt hast.
Das heißt, das ist eigentlich so dein Überprüfungsmodell, das ist so eine von drei verschiedenen Ansätzen, wie man äh überprüfen kann, ob das irgendwie funktioniert hat. Und dann läuft der Strom da, was weiß ich, was war auch nochmal so zehn, zwanzig Minuten irgendwie durch.
Drückt dann dann sozusagen so eine Spur von dieser Tasche aus zu dem anderen Pol in diesem Gel.
Mhm. Und ich nehme an, je kürzer die Dinger sind, umso schneller können die durch das Gel durchkommen.
Richtig. Genau und das ist halt der Punkt. Das heißt, das kannst du sehen. Dann brauchst du natürlich noch eine Skala und deswegen wird auch noch so eine dritte Tasche mit ähm speziellen Material durchpipediert, wo du quasi mehrere.
DNA-Stränge, wobei es dann egal ist, was es sich dabei handelt, da geht's nur dadrum, dass da mehrere drin sind, die alle verschiedene Längen haben. Und alles wiederum wird noch mit einem Farbstoff zusätzlich versehen, sodass er das auch visuell sehen kannst.
Das heißt, du hast deine Probe, die an irgendwelchen Stellen dann die DNR-Stränge äh quasi irgendwo absetzt. Du hast diese Gegenprobe, die eigentlich nichts absetzen sollte.
Und dann hast du quasi diese Skala-Material, was den Genstrenge in verschiedenen Längen hat und dann eben in regelmäßigen Abständen einen entsprechenden Farbfleck macht. Den kann man dann unter UV-Licht sich anschauen.
Und dann kannst du quasi an der Skala vergleichen so okay, alles klar, die Skala sagt das, das, das, was das, guckst du in deine eigene Probe an, siehst, aha, okay, ich habe meinen Strich jetzt hier, also muss dieser DNA-Strang so und so lang sein,
Und wenn das die Länge ist, die du haben wolltest, dann hast du gesehen, dass hier eben tatsächlich das der DNA-Ausschnit.
Den du jetzt nachweisen wolltest, vervielfacht wurde, weil er ist ja da sichtbar an dieser Stelle und dann weißt du, dass es positiv ist.
Also das war wirklich sehr äh interessant. Ich hab's ja eigentlich nicht so mit Biologie, Biochemie in all diesen ganzen äh Dingen, aber das äh hat mir dann gesagt, äh einiges gesagt, ne. Im bei den Corona Viren.
Wird es halt anders automatisiert, da es halt natürlich große Geräte, wo diese ganze Pipetiererei natürlich auch automatisch abläuft, weil das war natürlich ein längerer, manueller Prozess.
Und äh dort wird dann halt ähm mit so einer Farbüberprüfung das Ganze,
noch in der Maschine gemacht, das heißt, äh, du kannst also von Stufe zu Stufe mach das Ding quasi immer wieder äh quasi in in diesem Apparat selber ein Bild davon und kann dann daran schon äh erkennen.
Ob da eine Probe positiv ist oder nicht. Das mal so als hoffentlich einfach ausreichend einfache äh Erläuterung des was ich da gemacht habe.
Definitiv ein Prozess, den man sich auch gleich noch zwei, drei Mal durch den Kopf gehen lassen muss, aber war auf jeden Fall sehr äh aufschlussreich.
Es gibt auch ein paar ganz schöne Videos dazu im Netz. So äh auch über ja wie Fische, wie auch andere Tests äh jetzt noch äh funktionieren. Und so.
Ja, es gibt ja noch so andere Methoden, wie diesen sogenannten.
Der das alles nochmal abkürzt, der also theoretisch in der Lage wäre,
eine Überprüfung sehr viel schneller durchzuführen als die PCR-Tests, die es jetzt machen, aber diese PCR-Test sind halt sehr genau sehr geringe Fehleranfälligkeit.
Na ja in diesem ganzen Testszenario, was wir jetzt alle so durchleben, ist es nun mal so, dass der Betrieb dieser Maschinen ähm,
Ob das jetzt eine Stunde dauert oder ob das drei Stunden dauert,
macht im Großen und Ganzen jetzt nicht so den Unterschied, weil sehr viel mehr Probleme hast, schnell Proben zu entnehmen, zu transportieren, ankommen zu lassen, in die Systeme zu übergeben und natürlich dann auch die Rückmeldung zu machen.
Ähm ja, wenn man den Rest auch durchoptimiert bekäme, dann würde es vielleicht auch in eine schnellere Testmethode irgendwann nochmal Sinn machen, aber es scheint derzeit noch nicht so das Problem zu sein.
Aber na ja doch also ist es schon äh ein Problem und warum? Äh ja zeigt halt einen Blick auf die Zahlen und.
Ja, wir hatten, ich meine, wir haben ja unsere Sendung jetzt äh auf Freitag gelegt, weil Donnerstag oder Freitag so die Tage sind, an denen man immer spektakuläre äh neue Rekorde äh
sehen kann, weil ja, sagt christliche Logistik äh Funktion und so. Ähm.
Ja und so haben wir den äh heute auch ein,
neuen Rekord Tagesrekord mit einundzwanzigtausendsechsundfünfzig Neuinfektionen und auch einen neuen Rekord beim Sieben-Tagesschnitt ungefähr
siebzehntausend in den letzten sieben Tagen gemittelt, äh so.
Der sieben Tages-R-Wert ist dagegen auf ungefähr eins Komma eins gesungen.
Aber das ist nicht die gute Nachricht äh wie äh man jetzt denken könnte.
Sondern äh was wir da sehen, warum der RWT jetzt zurückgeht ist, weil wir äh definitiv in unsere Kapazitätsgrenzen für PCR-Tests reingelaufen sind.
So, das heißt, ähm was man sehen kann ist,
meine für diese Woche haben wir die Zahlen noch nicht, aber für die KW vierundvierzig werden sie ja mittwochs immer veröffentlicht. Da hatten wir sieben Komma zwei sechs Prozent.
Positive Tests.
Und ähm fünfundvierzig, genau war das. Ist die letzte, nicht vierundvierzig.
Also wir sind jetzt gerade am Ende von KW fünfundvierzig. Also wir sind am, wir sind am Freitag von Cabrio fünfundvierzig, also genau genommen Kaffee fünfundvierzig dauert jetzt noch zwei.
Okay, das ist die genau Neve, okay, die Zahlen sind dann für KW vierundvierzig und die Prognose ist für KW fünfundvierzig jetzt die Kapazitätsprognose.
So und in KW vierundvierzig wurden halt ähm ja.
Nicht ganz eins Komma sechs Millionen Tests durchgeführt mit einer positiven Quote von sieben Komma zwei sechs Prozent,
Das ist jetzt noch nicht der Rekord in Deutschland. Wir hatten Ende April in der KW vierzehn mal neun Prozent so, aber bei ungefähr einem Viertel der Tests, also bei vierhunderttausend Tests äh so,
Ähm und was man auch, woran man auch merkt, dass die Labore jetzt
einfach in die Sättigung reinlaufen, ist es wird halt auch ständig der Probenrückstau gemeldet und so ein Drittel der Labore hat gemeldet.
Dass sie insgesamt hunderttausend Proben haben, die sie nicht mehr am selben Tag geschafft haben zu bearbeiten. Das heißt
weil aber nur ein Drittel der Labore überhaupt einen Rückstau gemeldet haben, heißt das wenig erstens nicht, dass die anderen zwei Drittel der Labore,
alle keinen Rückstau hatten, ja? Sondern es heißt, dass die Labore, die einen Rückstand haben ungefähr
Ja im Schnitt für anderthalb Tage Proben rumliegen haben bevor sie in die Maschine kommen.
Also das heißt es sind Zusetz ist zusätzliche Wartezeit, ja? Zu dem was.
Nicht nur nicht nur zusätzliche Wartezeit, da kommt ja auch noch ein anderes Problem dazu. Diese Proben sind ja zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo sie im Labor ankommen, unter Umständen auch schon einen Tag, vielleicht sogar auch schon zwei Tage unterwegs, weil sie dann nicht rechtzeitig ab,
wurden und na ja, je nachdem wie diese Proben entnommen und wie sie dann auch transportiert werden, sind die halt auch nicht ewig haltbar.
Gut, ich habe jetzt einfach mal angenommen, dass die Labore, die zumindest dann irgendwie hier in einen Kühleinricht.
Das werden sie sicherlich tun, ja.
Wenn sie dies schon nicht bearbeitet kriegen, deswegen aber ja, besser werden die sicherlich auch nicht dadurch, äh wenn man sie liegen lässt, aber vermutlich bei richtiger Kühlung könnte ich mir vorstellen
So sollten hier eigentlich eher haltbar sein, zumal die ja nicht ja
die RNA äh ja ohnehin getestet wird, das heißt optivieren jetzt dabei.
Getötet werden oder nicht äh so oder inaktiviert werden, ist dann jetzt glaube ich nicht so das Problem, aber gut äh.
Schön ist es auf jeden Fall nicht und ja meine Eltern äh sind zum Beispiel am Montag getestet worden,
heute ist Freitag und die haben ihr Ergebnis noch immer nicht.
Na ja genau, also Wochen Wochenende ist natürlich nochmal ein extra Problem dann.
Nee, was heißt Wochenende? Von Montag? Ich mein Montag getestet.
Ach so, von Montag bis Freitag, oh.
Nicht von Freitag bis Montag, sondern.
So, ja, also das ist immer noch nicht da und es ist halt natürlich besonders erärgerlich, wenn man sich von der Quarantäne frei testen äh lassen will
ja und dann das Testergebnis am Ende der Quarantäne kommt, ja? Das ist das ja,
negiert so ein bisschen den Grund oder den Vorteil, warum man dann einen Test macht.
Irgendwie reißt, ja.
Also ähm wie gesagt, Probenrückstau, so so hoch äh wie nie. Und deswegen sind eben auch die Zahlen oder der zurückgegangene RWT einfach mit Vorsicht zu genießen,
was in Wirklichkeit passiert ist, ist, dass jetzt die Dummhülze fahr.
Vermutlich auch angestiegen ist und dass die Zahlen eigentlich höher sein müssen. Gut.
Dieses das haben wir schon öfter erlebt im Laufe der Pandimie und das wird sich irgendwann dann korrigieren, was dadurch eben wesentlich betroffen ist, ist der Ehrwert,
Schwankungen und die Form der Kurve ist eine andere, aber die Gesamtzahl sagen ja,
so also zumindest ob ob sie steigen
oder sinken oder gleichbleiben in etwa äh das können wir an den Zahlen ablesen. Das Verhältnis jetzt, wie stark sie steigen
und äh oder oder fallen, das ist immer mit Vorsicht zu genießen.
Da äh wobei man natürlich sehen kann, wenn sie besonders stark steigen, aber ja.
Auf jeden Fall nicht nicht schön und immerhin es war auch absehbar, weil man hat eigentlich schon vor einer Woche jetzt die Teststrategie auf den äh Herbst und Winter.
Angepasst, das heißt faktisch,
ist die Situation mal wieder nicht so, dass jeder, der äh will, sich testen lassen kann, offiziell oder nicht jeder soll getestet werden.
Und nicht jeder auch der Erkältungssymptome zeigt,
soll getestet werden, sondern eigentlich ist die Empfehlung, dass wenn Symptome, es ist entweder mehrere typische Corona-Symptome sind oder.
Dass es halt.
Typische Symptome sind in Verbindung mit entweder einer besonderen Gefährdung oder einer besonderen Unterbringungssituation oder einem besonderen Job.
Olaf ja ähm solche Dinge, das ist jetzt halt in der neuen Teststrategie
äh jetzt drin, das heißt, man fährt eigentlich wieder jetzt das Testen auch ein bisschen zurück, beziehungsweise ja
will weniger Leute testen, weil äh oder priorisieren beim Testen, weil klar ist, wir können gerade nicht mehr alle testen. So,
und das ist ehrlich gesagt ja auch ein bisschen Schuld am Festhalten, an den PCR-Tests oder am unzureichenden,
Ausbau der Testkapazitäten ja. Wir hatten bis vor einer Woche hatten wir ausreichend Kapazität.
Ja? Aber jetzt haben wir nicht mehr ausreichend Kapazität und äh dass,
ich sehe nicht, dass diese Situation sich äh zumindest mit PCA-Tests jetzt äh so schnell beheben lässt. Und deswegen ja bin ich nicht zufrieden, ja, mit der Gesamtsituation,
bleiben.
Gut, ich meine, das hängt so ein bisschen davon ab.
Was wir nicht wissen ist wie sehr die Laborkapazitäten noch hochgefahren werden können oder derzeit hochgefahren werden. Ne? Also es ist ja,
an vielen Stellen, also logistisch muss man dann äh mitarbeiten, äh braucht vor allem halt diese Geräte und die werden halt
wahrscheinlich auch gerade am Akkord produziert, weltweit verkauft und natürlich auch in Deutschland äh nachträglich eingerichtet, weil,
so schnell hat sich medizinisches Gerät wahrscheinlich noch nie armortisiert wie hier.
Ja, du kannst die wahrscheinlich innerhalb von, also wenn, wenn's gerade läuft, kannst du die recht schnell äh armatisieren, aber ähm,
Ja, wenn dann natürlich dieses erfolgreich bekämpfst und dann mehrere Monate.
Die Zahlen unten sind, dann stehen die Geräte halt erstmal wieder rum. Ähm so das ist also.
Ja gut, ich meine, wenn wenn sie sich amortisiert haben, haben sie sich halt auch armortisiert, also ich meine
die Kosten reinkriegst, dann äh können sie auch gerne noch ein bisschen rumstehen. Irgendjemand wird dafür schon eine Verwendung haben äh also.
Wie gesagt, wissen wir nicht, aber das ist schon etwas, was den Bike, weil du ja vorhin meintest, eine andere Testmethode wäre vielleicht äh ganz hilfreich, wenn die schneller laufen könnte, ja, theoretisch ist das so, nur dann müsste eben,
äh diese Testmethode
auch wirklich dieselbe Qualität haben, so was sie glaube ich so noch nicht ganz hat, das kriege ich jetzt nicht so ganz zusammen und du musst natürlich auch sehen, hm
diese ganzen Laborer haben sich quasi jetzt auf diese PCR-Methode, die ja auch einfach schon seit zwanzig Jahren existiert und zuverlässig ist, ja? Die man kennt, die man einschätzen kann, wo man alle Parameter jetzt für hat.
Die läuft, ja.
Und die zehn Mal so teuer ist äh wie ähm ja Alternativen, die nicht so gut sind, aber ja.
Ja gut, aber das ist halt äh äh das, was jetzt da ist und von dem man weiß, dass es funktioniert ist, das hat ja auch einen Wert in sich und äh vor allem, wenn du eben auch entsprechende Geräte bekommen kannst. Na ja, also.
Es ist wie es ist, wie man so schön sagt. Ähm.
Okay, vielleicht nochmal zurück zu den Zahlen, also einundzwanzigtausend Neuinfektionen,
jetzt natürlich die Frage, wie sieht's,
aus im akuten Krankenhaus und Todesfallszenario, weiß nicht, die Krankenhauszahlen haben wir jetzt, glaube ich, nicht zusammengetragen, wenn ich das richtig sehe oder hast du die irgendwo.
Nee, die Krankenhauszahlen haben wir jetzt nicht, aber die Zahlen sind leider extrem nach oben geschossen.
Sowohl bundesweit so als auch in Berlin. Also so.
Ja so viele Menschen sind jetzt seit ja Ende Mitte, Mitte Mai äh nicht mehr gestorben im Schnitt pro Woche.
Und der Anstieg ist aber äh ja dramatisch und weil wir wissen wie die,
Zahlen, äh die infizierten Zahlen gestiegen sind, können wir ungefähr absehen, äh auch, dass diese Zahlen äh gerade bei den Toten.
Ja vermutlich Faktor fünf bis zehn von dem erreichen werden.
Was heute war und ja heute also die der Durchschnitt bereits bei über hundert Toten bundesweit, der sieben Tagesdurchschnitt.
Und ähm ja.
Jeder sieben der sieben Tagesdurchschnitt liegt bei siebenhundertfünfzig.
Also äh sozusagen jetzt der auf sieben Tage gemittelte Tagesdurchschnitt.
Ach so, okay. Mhm. Ja.
Also ja.
Gut, dass du das äh nochmal präzisiert und äh korrigiert hast, ja. Also äh und dementsprechend äh ich meine.
Es sind zwar wahrscheinlich noch äh ein, zwei, drei Wochen äh äh,
wenn das jetzt weiter nach oben geht bis äh das Gesundheitssystem seine Kapazitätsgrenzen erreicht hat und ich glaube in einigen Gegenden werden wir da auch rein äh rennen.
Ähm aber hoffentlich hoffentlich greif.
Der Lokdown bei uns dann ähnlich wie in Israel, bevor es ganz schlimm wird, bevor es flächendeckend schlimm wird.
So
Also ich meine, wenn man sich vor allem jetzt äh auf deiner Grafik anschaut, wie sich Infektionszahlen zu Todeszahlen verhalten.
Wir hatten ja üblicherweise, also nicht mehr so mal das anschaue bei der ersten Welle. Na ja, das ging schon so vier Wochen hinterher.
Und na ja.
Ja, also hier ist jetzt sozusagen im im Bild, muss man dazu sagen, ist jetzt sagen bei den Todeszahlen ist jetzt Faktor zehn äh so, also sie sind jetzt um zehn Mal vergrößert, aber äh.
Ja, aber sie steigen halt, sie werden doch eine Weile ansteigen. So, also das ist also selbst wenn
die Infektionshallen können wir jetzt nicht so richtig einschätzen, wenn's jetzt richtig, richtig gut läuft, ja? Und äh die mit ihren Probenrückstrauch hinterherkommen und jetzt äh alle auch ordentlich sich mal an die Maßnahmen halten würden, dann wird es ja jetzt noch mindestens eine Woche dauern
bis wir das R so richtig so gedreht bekommen, dass auch die Infektion, die neuen Infektionszahlen auch sichtbar wieder zurückgehen. Und,
dann dauert's nochmal eine Woche oder zwei, bis die in,
ähm Bereich vorstoßen, wo man sagen kann, die Lage bessert sich jetzt auch wieder. Und dann sind immer nochmal vier Wochen
ähm später die Auswirkungen davon zu spüren. Also das heißt diese Entwicklung der Todesfälle wird sich bis in den Dezember reinziehen.
Also wahrscheinlich genau, wahrscheinlich werden wir erst im Dezember den Höhepunkt äh erreichen, wenn äh wenn wir Glück haben, ja.
Und ähm ja, bei den derzeitigen Verdopplungsraten äh habe ich mir das vorstelle, äh könnten wir.
Halt bis dahin auf tausend Tote am Tag äh äh hochkommen.
Was natürlich ziemlich bitter wäre.
Aber das lässt sich wahrscheinlich jetzt kaum noch vermeiden.
Nee, weil das die Infektionen sind, die haben jetzt alle schon stattgefunden. Tja, wie sagtest du so schön? Weihnachten wird ungemütlich, dass äh.
Kann man jetzt glaube ich bestätigen und ich denke man kann jetzt auch schon mal festhalten. Wir haben eigentlich jetzt mit diesem zweiten Lokdown zu spät angefangen. Also es ist einfach mindestens vier Wochen zu spät.
Aber auch glaube ich schon vor zwei vor in der letzten Woche und vor zwei Wochen gesagt, dass es jetzt irgendwie zu spät kommt,
und dann ja rechnen wir halt immer noch, dass es zu Verschärfungen äh kommen wird. Ich meine die Situation in Deutschland ist im Vergleich mit anderen Ländern äh noch gut.
In anderen Ländern wie in Belgien oder in Tschechien. Ähm.
Da ist teilweise äh mittlerweile das Militär äh im Einsatz, um zu helfen, ja.
Ähm also da haben wir in in einigen Ländern äh wieder äh Verhältnisse, wo das Gesundheitssystem definitiv nicht mehr mitkommt.
Trotz äh ja hartem Lock kommen da vielleicht noch hinterher bei der internationalen Situation.
Genau, seid ihr nochmal ein bisschen was zu Berlin vielleicht.
Ja, Berlin äh so ist jetzt wieder nach vorne gerückt, so in meiner Risikotabelle.
Aber vielleicht nochmal ganz kurz zum zum Ländervergleich so um jetzt Deutschland mal abzuschließen nochmal.
Ähm so in den Top dreißig Augsburg ist jetzt Top Hotspot in meiner äh Risikotabelle und überhaupt ist jetzt sind die Top dreißig jetzt äh wieder zwölf Mal,
von bayrischen Landkreisen, gefüllt, sechs Mal ist Nordrhein-Westfalen dabei, viermal Sachsen, Berlin ist wieder zweimal vertreten,
Und dann haben wir noch Niedersachsen, Rheinland-Pfalz und Hessen auch jeweils zweimal äh nee, Hessen nur einmal und äh die anderen,
warten jeweils zweimal drin. So und ähm bei den Bundesländern
so sind jetzt wieder Berlin und äh Sachsen vor NRW und Bayern
Bayern auch wieder nach vorne gerückt. Hamburg äh liegt dahinter, aber wahrscheinlich auch wieder zu weit hinten platziert, weil die Zahlen in Hamburg immer noch mehrere Tage hinterherlaufen.
So, ich habe Spaßeshalber nochmal einen Run gemacht, den habe ich jetzt nicht grafisch ausgewertet, wo ich einfach nur mal geguckt habe, jetzt die Durchschnitte statt.
Für die letzten drei Monate habe ich nochmal für die für die letzten drei Wochen.
Genommen und da ist ganz klar in Hamburg hat sich da nichts verändert oder so Hamburg braucht halt grundsätzlich ein Tag mehr wie wir.
Wissen, weil sie irgendwie Zahlen morgens zusammenzählen und damit eigentlich immer nur praktisch die Zahlen vom Vortag, sowieso am Abend melden, das heißt, da kommt sowieso immer.
In Hamburg allein schon deswegen einen Tag dazu, aber ähm auch ansonsten scheinen sie nicht die Schnellsten zu sein.
Die Hamburger Nomalie hat sich auch nichts geändert.
Ja ja, nee, die Hamburg Anomalie ist äh auf jeden Fall immer noch da und deutlich an den Zahlen.
Ja
Und wie gesagt Berlin jetzt so ein bisschen mit dem Bund, was den RWT angeht gleich auf.
Einiges noch mit ja dort mit etwas höheren Institzen,
und ja an der Spitze wechseln sich halt jetzt ja Neukölln ist im Moment wieder vorne aber an sich
ist es auch so ein bisschen müßig, ich sag mal in Berlin bei den hohen Zahlen
dann noch zu differenzieren, die gehen im einen Bezirk hoch und wieder runter, um im anderen wieder hoch und runter zu gehen. Also es wabert jetzt quasi überall so durch Berlin, wobei
schon die reinen Ostbezirke nur einmal doch eher weiter dazu tendieren sich am Ende der Tabelle aufzuhalten und die Ostbezirke und insbesondere,
ja auch so eigentlich eher mal einkommensschwächere Bezirke wie Neukölln
Kreuzberg eher nach vorne aufzutauchen oder auch Spandau. Im Moment ist Tempelhof Schöneberg auch recht weit vorne, aber ja,
So vielleicht noch ja doch noch zu Berlin noch eine Sache. Ich hab halt,
die rechnen halt auch immer die aktuellen Institenzen in den unterschiedlichen Altersgruppen für Berlin. Ich hab jetzt noch nicht die passenden, immer noch nicht die passenden Zahlen für die Bundesländer.
Ähm aber für Berlin mache ich's halt immer und ja, da sieht man.
Nach wie vor in der Altersgruppe fünfzehn bis vierunddreißig.
Die dominieren äh mit über äh dreihundert so berlinweit
die zweithöchste Altersgruppe ist jetzt leider die achtzig plus mit,
Über zweihundertfünfzig aufgrund mehrerer Ausbrüche in Altersheim, also es ist definitiv so leider, leider hat es eben die,
ganz alten jetzt äh ungewöhnlich heftig erwischt. Ähm so die niedrigsten Institenzen sind interessanterweise,
In der Altersgruppe null bis vier und in der sechzig bis neunundsiebzig,
Ähm wobei man, was ich jetzt auch gelernt habe bei,
Kleinkindern so in dem Alter äh wird auch nicht so viel getestet äh so. Äh das ist ein bisschen äh,
auch das Ding. Ähm, da muss man überhaupt bei Kleinkindern äh.
Nicht nur bei den ganz kleinen Kindern überhaupt bei Kindern, weil weil einfach Symptome nicht, ne,
Wie wir ja wissen, nicht so äh privat sind und gerade wenn man jetzt eine Teststrategie haben, die primär nach Symptomen geht, werden wir da halt eher den Anteil noch sinken sehen, aber das natürlich die Gruppe achtzig Plus.
Ähm jetzt so stark betroffen ist. Das wird natürlich leider dazu führen, dass eben die Todeszahlen den Segment natürlich nochmal richtig nach oben gehen.
Das ist bitter. Ähm ja.
Wir könnten jetzt nochmal einen Blick auf andere Länder werfen. Haben wir ja haben wir ja schon mal.
Gesprochen, also Europa hat auf jeden Fall eine Menge zu bieten. Also ich weiß gar nicht, was es insgesamt, wenn man jetzt mal nur die.
Belgien hat definitiv den Vogel abgeschossen, so muss man sagen und hat eine Rekordinstität, glaube ich, von fast tausendvierhundert pro.
Ähm eine Million pro Tag erreicht so und ja,
das ist irre und äh,
knapp gefolgt von Tschechien, die heute einen auch einen neu oder gestern einen neuen Tagesrekord wert.
Trotz jetzt mittlerweile eine ganze Weile und äh rückläufiger,
sieben Tageswerte, also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass es da wieder jetzt explodiert, aber es ist natürlich schon so ein bisschen unschön, wenn man denkt, oh, jetzt ist es äh zum Stillstand gekommen, beziehungsweise die Zahlen gehen nach unten,
Und dann hagelt dir so ein neuer Tagesrekord rein, das ist dann schon so ein bisschen frustrierend, aber man darf einfach,
nicht auf einzelne Tage gucken, den Fehler sollte man nicht machen. Man muss sich irgendwie eigentlich immer nur die sieben Tageswerte
angucken und da scheint der Rekord überschritten zu sein und auch wenn man sich anguckt, wie das in Israel gelaufen ist
da gab's dann auch erstmal 'n kleinen Einbruch so, dann ging's dann nochmal hoch für
Ja, ein paar Wochen äh tatsächlich äh und.
Zackte so Kronenmäßig wie so eine so ein, ja, äh auch der sieben sieben Tagesschnitt, so ging dann mal rauf, mal runter bis dann irgendwann äh ja
dann endgültig der Abwärtstrend da war und.
Insofern kann man nur hoffen, dass Tschechien und Belgien, dass da jetzt der Abwärtstrend weitergeht, weil das sind so ein bisschen dann auch unsere Vorbilder
eigentlich wo wir dran sehen können, was ist jetzt stärker der Winter oder der Lockdown?
Wie er uns der gute Herr Professor Drosten äh äh da erklärt hat in einem der Podcasts hat's in Argentinien nicht geklappt, so trotz Lokdown äh das Ganze in den Griff zu kriegen, weil dort Winter war.
Ich will die Zahlen nochmal so ein bisschen in äh in Perspektive setzen. Also derzeit weist Tschechien, eine Zahl von tausendzweiundneunzig.
Ähm Day Rolling Everic, also quasi in einer Woche im Schnitt.
Tausend Leute, sage ich jetzt mal, infizieren sich. Von einer Million. Das heißt, jeder Tausendste in diesem Land.
Infiziert sich, binnen einer Woche.
Bin eines Tages. Das sind die Zahlen pro Tag,
und pro Million. Wenn du die jetzt auf unsere übliche, übliche Institenz per hunderttausend auf die sieben Tage Institz umrechnen willst, äh muss so quasi die Zahl mal sieben nehmen und durch.
Teilen. Also.
Ist es okay, dann ist es also noch.
Ungefähr ist ungefähr dieselbe Größenordnung, ja? Aber ist hal.
Also es ist ein Tageswert. Okay, das das macht die Sache ja dann gleich noch sieben Mal so schlimm. Also das heißt jeden Tag infiziert sich eintausendstel der Bevölkerung.
Yeah. Also wahrscheinlich mehr, weil das ist ohne Dunkelziffer. Das ist sozusagen.
Ja, also nachgewiesener Maßen. So äh.
Mhm. Mindestens.
Mindestens okay, jetzt nehmen wir mal irgendeine Dunkelziffer an, was würdest du gerade für eine vertretbare äh Zahl in Raum werfen?
Eher mindestens drei.
Mal so zurückhaltend, ne?
Mindestens, ja, als Untergrenze, damit wir nicht als wie jetzt hier Übertreiber gelten, aber.
Ja okay, aber das heißt null Komma drei Prozent der Bevölkerung pro Tag. Das ist schon äh eine Menge Holz.
Ja, das ist eine Menge, aber leider dann doch wieder nicht genug.
Um äh ja auf äh oder um jetzt schnell zur Herdenimmunität äh zu kommen oder dass sich das irgendwie bemerkbar machen würde, großartig und die Infektion verlangsamen würde. Ja.
Na gut, aber ich meine, wir sind ja schon beim Fünftel davon, ne? Also uns dauert's halt ein. Also wie man's dreht und findet, ist auf jeden Fall alles nicht gut und die Zahlen müssen definitiv runterkommen. So, es es sei denn, man gibt auf.
Ja und ganz schlimm äh ist es aber auch in Tschechien jetzt äh bei der Zahl der Todesopfer. Die Leute sterben da jetzt gerade leider auch in.
Größeren äh ja in größeren Zahlen und ähm.
Wenn man sich hier die Dritte von meinen Grafiken anguckt,
ist äh.
Also Tschechien hat einen Durchschnittswert von zwanzig Toten pro Million pro Tag.
Also jeder fünfzigtausendste sozusagen. Stirbt jeden Tag.
Ja, aber wenn man sich, also man kann sich, wenn man jetzt sagen, die die Zahlen der Toten vergleicht, äh kann man irgendwie zwei Dinge äh sich angucken, einmal natürlich den Durchschnitt der neuen Fälle,
der in Tschechien auch so im Europavergleich sogar über Belgien jetzt.
Ähm und wenn man sich aber jetzt die Gesamtzahl anschaut, also sozusagen komuliert.
Sieht man, dass Tschechien ja erstmal in der ersten Welle sehr gut weggekommen ist so und deutlich
drunter lag und jetzt aber in der zweiten Welle so alle anderen so ein Land nach dem anderen hinter sich lässt
allerdings noch, man muss sagen, leider noch deutlich besser äh ist in der Gesamtzahl, als jetzt Schweden oder Frankreich oder Italien
oder UK oder Spanien oder gar Belgien aber,
es sieht nicht so aus, als wenn das lange so bleiben würde, sondern äh ja die,
verlieren jetzt grade alles was sie in der ersten Welle gewonnen haben. So komplett.
Aber das alles gefährdet nicht den Spitzenplatz von Belgien. Also auch da geht die Kurve wieder gnadenlos nach oben und man fragt sich langsam, was eigentlich bitte in Belgien,
so unglaublich schief läuft, dass sie also schon immer Rekordhalter waren von allem, also es ist einfach auch das von von sagen wir mal Ländern, die jetzt nicht so Vatikan statt Größe haben, ähm einfach das am stärksten,
betroffenen Land, so. Und das ist echt krass.
Also ich kann's mir auch nicht so richtig,
erklären, ich mein gut Belgien ist ja halt auch bekannt dafür, dass sie mal auch ein Jahr ohne Regierung oder so gefahren
sind und man das jetzt auch nicht so richtig gemerkt hat, dass es irgendeinen Unterschied groß gemacht hat. Gut, jetzt vielleicht auch mal übertrieben, aber äh ja, Belgien
ist mir auch unklar warum, dass da dermaßen äh fehlgeschlagen ist.
Also in Belgien ist jetzt quasi laut diesen Zahlen bisher äh eintausendstel der Bevölkerung gestorben an dieser Pandemie.
Ja. Mhm.
Null Komma eins Prozent. Das ist jetzt gar nicht so wenig.
Ne.
Auf Deutschland umgerechnet, wenn in Deutschland so viele Leute gestorben wären, äh,
ein Prozent wären achthunderttausend, es werden es achtzigtausend.
Deutsche Verhältnisse auf die auf die dreiundachtzigtausend fünfundneunzigtausend, was ist ein bisschen mehr als irgendwie tausendfünfzig oder so glaube ich.
Ja, tausendfünfundsechzig, egal. Ja, also Belgien äh ist eine Katastrophe und äh ja,
Spanien allerdings läuft's auch nicht so gut, wobei die hatten ein Zellproblem, die haben da am vierten November nochmal einen ganzen Schwung Fälle, die irgendwo stecken geblieben sind, dann äh dazu addiert.
Ja und dann kommt aber schon in der Gesamtbilanz Brasilien in USA und UK.
Sogar Italien ist bisher noch besser davon gekommen bei der Zahl der Toten als jetzt UK und USA aber ja in Italien geht's aber auch wieder leider nach oben.
Frankreich auch Schweden sieht irgendwie verdächtig flach aus bei der Zahl der Toten bisher.
Da scheint sich noch nicht so richtig was zu rühren. Es ist interessant.
Auf einmal ist der schwedische Weg wieder interessant,
Also ich denke, dass dass teilt alles jetzt auch so nicht nur Wellen, die jetzt in die Länder schwappen, es ist halt auch wirklich eine Welle, die die quer durch Europa schwimmt und äh nur weil wir jetzt gerade mal sehr viel besser dastehen als irgendein anderes Land, kann's nicht sein, äh heißt es noch lange nicht, dass es uns nicht
ähm in einem Monat genauso wieder erwischen kann und.
Ja zumal wir ja jetzt auch erstmal nur behutsam auf die Bremse getreten sind, also deutlich behutsamer als jetzt
ja Israel oder Tschechien oder Belgien oder Frankreich oder Italien
so wo die Lokdowns deutlich schärfer ausfallen. Ja,
Aber wie gesagt, noch kein Notstand bei uns, aber in einigen,
europäischen Ländern ist, herrscht tatsächlich echter Notstand und nicht nur auf dem Papier, sondern ja da.
Werden gerade Patienten ausgeflogen in Nachbarländer und so, weil man.
Land nicht mehr mitkommt und gut Deutschland hat auch noch den Vorteil, so dass wir hier alles irgendwie langsamer geht, ist hier halt auch der Abbau des Gesundheitssystems nicht so richtig vorragend gekommen, muss man sagen, der neoliberale,
Ähm so äh ja.
Und insofern ja stehen wir jetzt halt auch noch ein bisschen besser äh da, was einfach die Betten zahlen und so angeht. Aber da haben wir auch ja schon gesehen
dass die Bettenzahlen wahrscheinlich ein bisschen höher sind äh als ähm ja das
verfügbare Personal, wobei ich halt auch weiß, dass dann geplant ist, dass dann halt andere äh Kräfte abgezogen werden, um dann gegebenenfalls äh ja,
Kowittpatienten zu betreuten. Halt, dann hast du halt keine Ahnung als Neurologe oder so, machst du dann keine Hirn-OPs mehr, sondern stehst dann irgendwie am Bett oder so und beatmest dann äh Kovit-Patienten oder so.
Nun du, ähm jetzt gab's ein paar.
Interessante äh Veröffentlichung auch nochmal zu der Dunkelziffer. Es gab in München nochmal eine Antikörperstudie, die veröffentlicht worden ist,
Du hast dir das angeschaut, was was liest du denn daraus? Also.
Äh ja, also es ist auf jeden Fall ein weiterer Datenpunkt und auch einen,
ganz interessanter Datenpunkt, was jetzt so die Sterblichkeit angeht, aber.
Natürlich war's jetzt auch wieder nicht so eine unbedingt repräsentative.
Gruppe muss das dann wieder umrechnen ähm so auf ja damit das irgendwie repräsentativ ist und ähm ja äh,
Und dann haben wir aber gesehen, oder ist jetzt klar, dass die Dunkelziffer ähm zu unterschiedlichen Zeitpunkten,
unterschiedlich groß ist, weil ja je nachdem wie stark sich die Infektion grade ausbreitet oder eben sich im Rückgang,
befindet äh ja ändert sich die Dunkelziffer und,
ist unterschiedlich in verschiedenen Altersgruppen, das heißt je nachdem wo dann gerade in welcher Altersgruppe das Ganze rassiert
ändert das natürlich auch die Dunkelziffer, weil wenn das mehr bei den Jüngeren grasiert, die dann Symptomarm sind, lassen die sich natürlich auch nicht testen, das heißt
so eine höhere Dunkelziffer während bei Älteren, wo sich dann Symptome zeigen, ist dann auch die äh Dunkelziffer niedriger, das heißt diese,
Dunkelziffer ist äh leider einen viel dynamischerer
wert äh so äh das heißt, was wir halt in dieser Studie haben ist halt eine Momentaufnahme äh der Dunkelziffer in diesem,
bestimmten Zeitraum äh in dem äh da die Erhebung stattgefunden hat. Und.
Auch wieder interessant. Ich habe seinen ersten Presseartikel äh äh dazu gelesen, so wo die Studie zitiert wurde
und da stand dann drin, kam es zu einer Infektion, dann verbreitete diese sich nicht nur innerhalb des betroffenen Haushaltes eine leichte Häufung, war auch in dem Wohnhaus und in einem
Umkreis von bis zu zweihundert Metern festzustellen. So, das klingt natürlich erstmal oh.
Stecke ich mich jetzt irgendwie an, weil meine Nachbarn jetzt so.
Ja irgendwie schon wobei.
In den Presseartikel wurde es dann damit begründet, das liegt dann mehr darin, dass sie auch in dieselben Kneipen gehen und in dieselben Geschäfte einkaufen gehen und jetzt nicht notwendigerweise, weil die das Fenster die ganze Zeit aufhaben und ich auch und so und
Äh ja oder äh weiß ich nicht, das Treppenhaus irgendwie durchseucht ist.
Aber der Punkt war, als ich dann in die Studie geguckt habe.
Stand da drin, äh dass aber die Infektionshäufung statistisch nicht signifikant war. Zwar höher äh so, aber nicht statistisch signifikant. Also im Grunde genommen ja.
Eine leichte Kuriosität, aber tatsächlich äh hängt das individuelle Risiko äh jetzt nicht wie wenn man das,
Jetzt alleine so sieht massiv davon ab, wo man jetzt grade wohnt, sondern äh ich denke mehr auch vom eigenen Verhalten und nicht so sehr vom vom Wohnort.
Aber klar, wenn natürlich jeder zweite in meiner Gegend irgendwie infiziert ist, geht das auch nicht vollkommen spurlos an mir vorbei oder an meinem Risiko.
Wert, den ich dann habe.
Also die Dunkelziffer liegt weiter im Dunkeln, das kann man, glaube ich, äh erstmal festhalten.
Ja, aber also sagt, wir haben also irgendwo.
Schwankt sie, ich sage mal zwischen zweiundzwanzig bei uns eher so zwischen zwei und acht bisher.
Würde ich sagen ist eine Nummer, die die Studie deutete, glaube ich, auf Faktor vier hin in dem in dem
Zeitraum was jetzt realistisch ist meine Risikotabelle arbeitet immer noch mit sechs Komma zwei fünf, obwohl verschiedene Leute mich auch gefragt haben mal wieder ja es ist ja jetzt niedriger willst du nicht irgendwie,
auch die, du hast mich das glaube ich auch schon gefragt, ob ich jetzt nicht die Zahl runtersetzen will und,
ja vor drei oder vier Wochen, also wenn die Situation jetzt noch weiter so gelaufen wäre, ähm,
wie vor einem Monat oder zwei Monaten und sagen können, ja macht wohl Sinn
weil dann sind wir näher am echten Risiko dran. Jetzt gerade aktuell äh bewegt sich die Dunkelziffer wieder auf die sechs Komma zwei fünf zu. Also zögere ich. Da wird jetzt äh mit der Dunkelziffer runterzugehen
wenn und das Ganze sollte ja auch eher immer ein oberer Grenzwert sein, deswegen war das bewusst hochgewählt, weil.
Ich jetzt auch nicht verharmlosen wollte, jetzt auch nicht absolut so autländisch, Faktor zehn oder zwanzig, aber äh sie sechs Komma zwei fünf war zu dem Zeitpunkt wissenschaftlich abgedeckt und ich.
Werde auch nochmal neue eigene Berechnungen machen, vielleicht baue ich ja auch irgendwann mal was ein, äh was dann.
Nochmal auch die Zahlen oder die Dunkelziffer abschätzt, rückwirkend in einem gewissen Korridor.
Als Orientierung, aber.
Ja man könnte es ja zumindest so auch an diese Testzahlen und die positiven Quote äh äh festmachen, ne.
Also als wir wirklich eine nie niedrige positive Quote hatten, also bei vielen Test,
kaum jemand putzig wird, da könnte man halt sagen, ja okay, also wenn wir so viele Tests machen und wir wischen wirklich kaum noch jemanden, dann kann jetzt auch nicht die Dunkelziffer nochmal sechs mal so hoch sein. Aber jetzt, wo sie halt auch wieder steigt
auf sieben acht Prozent. Ähm na ja und wir auch sehen Testkapazitäten, Rücklauf, äh Probenrückstau
all diese ganzen Sachen, das äh fließt mit ein. Was da jetzt der richtige Faktor ist, das weiß keiner. Da kann man jetzt irgendwas nehmen, aber die Borussia dazu sagen, deine Tabelle,
lebt jetzt nicht von dieser Dunkelziffer, sondern es ist ausschließlich vorne diese Spalte, die dir quasi sagt, na ja, wie viele Zombies äh hast du so im Bus.
Und äh wie vorsichtig solltest du sozusagen sein und wenn man so ein so ein Gefühl bekommt für ah okay, so wie das jetzt gerade ist, mit
Unglück, was man so annehmen kann und der entsprechenden Dunkelziffer ist halt derzeit hier in meinem Feld jeder fünfzigste potenziell ansteckend,
und dass dass es sozusagen eine Zahl, mit der man einfach aus dem Haus rausgehen sollte oder am besten gar nicht rausgehen sollte.
Ja und äh tatsächlich, aber äh wenn ich auch einen netten Rat einfach,
eigentlich davon ständig davon auszugehen möglichst, dass man infektiös sein könnte, weil.
Viele Leute eben symptomfrei sind, das heißt man weiß es nicht, man kann es eigentlich nie,
Im Moment nicht garantieren, das heißt, verhalte dich so, als sei es zu infiziert und äh verhalte dich anderen Leuten gegenüber so, als seien sie infiziert so. Das äh,
Markt zwar jetzt ein bisschen übervorsichtig klingen und äh ist jetzt sicherlich auch im eigenen Haushalt, aber selbst da sollte man vielleicht es nicht äh ja es nicht übertreiben.
Viel beachtet in dieser Woche war auch ein Vortrag, den äh Christian Drosten gehalten hat in einer Schule irgendwo im Niedersachsen, glaube ich, wo er, also in Meppen war das,
wo er wohl ohnehin war, weil er da seine Eltern besucht hat oder so, weiß nicht ganz genau, äh also er ist jetzt nicht gerade äh unterwegs äh von einer Talkshow in die andere. Das betont er ja auch regelmäßig, wie unangenehm ihm. Diese mh,
Art der Auseinandersetzung ist und das wie gar nicht so sein Ding ist. Aber dort hat er dann mal Zeit gehabt. Man hat mal,
das gemacht, was ich finde, was man eben eh machen sollte, ihm mal so zwanzig, dreißig Minuten eingeräumt, einfach mal die aktuelle Situation, so aus einer Perspektive vorzustellen.
Und ja, das hat er dann auch in äh Ruhe äh gemacht. Hast du dir auch angeschaut, ne?
Habe ich mir auch angeschaut und äh ja ich fand das äh auf jeden Fall auch sehr inspirierend und erhellend und äh mir ist natürlich auch immer wichtig, so zu gucken, okay äh.
Bestätigt er jetzt Dinge, äh die von denen ich auch überzeugt bin oder,
hat er, wo hat er eine andere Meinung möglicherweise oder eine andere Sicht und ja lass mich da eventuell auch gerne sagen. Äh.
Belehren oder informieren oder auch äh ja zu einer Meinungs äh Änderung äh,
bringen, wenn ja da überzeugende Argumente kommen und glücklicherweise stelle ich immer wieder fest, ja äh so äh bin ich eigentlich.
Nicht weit entfernt äh so bei meinen Überzeugungen,
Es gibt da so ein paar Dinge, wo ich irgendwie, wo es dann aber tatsächlich auch um Einschätzungen gibt, wo ich sage mal, auch er sagt.
Er weiß es nicht wirklich und ist widersprüchliche Studien gibt und da ist so ein bisschen das Thema Schule so, äh wo er zwar auch sagt, ja ähm irgendwie Schulen,
also Kinder auf jeden Fall sind genauso anstecken,
wie Erwachsene. Und zu wie vielen Ansteckungen es allerdings in Schulen kommt ähm so, dass es halt umstritten und er,
verteidigt zumindest von seiner Meinung her äh jetzt, dass die Schulen offen gehalten wurden,
so. Obwohl man ihm anmerkt eigentlich, dass er so richtig, also dass er da so ein bisschen mit sich hadert hat, aber da auch gesagt.
Gut, das ist jetzt eine Woche her, äh dass er das irgendwie richtig findet. Grundsätzlich.
Faktisch dagegen ist es ein Experiment. Bisher sieht es so aus, als würde es noch.
Okay laufen, also zumindest konnte ich jetzt,
in dieser Altersgruppe fünf bis fünfzehn in Berlin zumindest noch keine,
keine signifikantes Ansteigen der Inzidenz fest im Vergleich zu anderen, sondern die sind,
unauffällig eher so im unteren Mittelfeld diese Altersgruppe. So ist die Frage gut wie zuverlässig sind die Zahlen in dieser Altersgruppe wenn sich da kaum jemand infiziert.
Bei der Zahl der Schulen, die geschlossen werden ähm.
So richtig transparenz nicht gegeben, also es gibt jetzt kein Register oder so. Ähm wo man jetzt gucken könnte, okay,
bundesweit, wie viel Schulen haben denn jetzt auf oder zu, es gab,
da ab und zu mal Auswertungen oder Meldungen oder Momentaufnahmen, aber ähm so ein bisschen läuft das da eher unter vorgehaltener Hand. So und,
Ich bin eher.
Also mir macht die aktuelle Situation und die Entwicklung der Zahlen glaube ich etwas größere Sorgen als äh jetzt
sie zum Ausdruck gebracht hat und er hat eigentlich war ziemlich davon überzeugt, dass es nicht zu einer Überlastung des Gesundheitssystems kommen wird und dass wir
eigentlich auch zur richtigen Zeit noch jetzt auf die Bremse getreten sind. Also bei ihm schien da nicht so viel Dringlichkeit
jetzt äh rauszuklingen. Äh also ich bin da nicht so entspannt wie er,
sondern äh ja ich habe da durchaus größere Sorge ähm,
dass ja dass es zu spät kommt beziehungsweise ich bin der Meinung wir hätten eigentlich eins oder zwei Wochen früher reagieren sollen, das wäre besser gewesen dann.
Oder hätte er sicherlich nichts dagegen gehabt, ne? Aber ich denke, er hat auch genug äh Kontakt schon mit der Realpolitik gesammelt, um zu wissen, dass es äh äh immer ein zähes Ringen ist.
Ja, definitiv ähm aber ja er hat auch interessant,
bisschen sagen was äh denn jetzt die Diskussion sind, so die Strategien eigentlich für die Zukunft, sodass wir vielleicht fast sehr interessanteste Teil und da.
Kam auch durchaus ein paar Dinge, die mir noch nicht so klar waren, dass die gerade von der Regierung erwogen werden und das eine.
Ist halt ähm ja das Testregime komplett,
umzustellen und auch äh ja eine komplette Umstellung bei der Art und Weise, wie gemeldet und erfasst äh wird
und,
auch 'ne Änderung bei der Strategie wie Carantinisiert wird und wer quarantinisiert wird. So das war.
So die äh die Dinge ähm weiß jetzt nicht, inwieweit wir im Einzelnen darauf darauf eingehen sollten.
Ja gut, ich meine, er ist ja immer den Clustern auf der Sp
ne? Das ist ja so seine seine klare These äh äh derzeit so äh Cluster, Cluster, Cluster, man muss sich sozusagen auf die starken Ausbrüche konzentrieren und wenn man halt sozusagen ein äh Cluster ausfindig gemacht hat, dann sollte man eben möglichst viele Leute, die äh diesem Cluster zugehörig äh sind oder sein können.
Möglichst schnell in Quarantäne schicken. Das ist eigentlich dieses südkoreanische Modell, was wir hier schon vor.
In einem halben Jahr glaube ich besprochen haben, was ja da von Anfang an für relativ äh große Erfolge gesorgt hat und ich glaube auch in Japan.
Und was hier so noch nicht so richtig im Vordergrund steht, ne.
Gut, was vielleicht dann nicht so klar.
Wenn man sich den Podcast anhört rauskommt ist was das dann jetzt konkret
bedeutet für die Leute
Südkorea bedeutete das zum Beispiel, dass halt dann erstmal zweihunderttausend Anhänger
dieser christlichen Insekte in Quarantäne geschickt wurden, ganz unabhängig davon,
wen sie wann, wie getroffen haben, wenn du irgendwie Mitglied dieser Sekte warst, warst du aufgefordert dich sofort in Quarantäne zu begeben oder dass dann halt,
auch ja sämtliche.
Leute, die auf irgendeiner Veranstaltung waren bei irgendeinem Sportereignis oder bei irgendeiner Demo.
Du warst irgendwie auf der Antikowito.
So. Wir hatten da vier Infektionen äh deswegen alle,
sagen, Anhänger äh äh alle, die auf der Anti-Kovic äh Demo äh waren oder äh da zufällig durchgelatscht sind. Äh ähm,
Ja sind kriegen dann wird dann Funkzellenabfrage gemacht zum Beispiel und dann kriegst du halt wenn du dich dann zu dem Zeitpunkt in der Funkzelle aufgehalten hast oder so möglicherweise Aufforderungen dich in Quarantäne zu begeben
Aha.
Gut, das geht jetzt ein bisschen weit, ne? Äh, nicht, dass wir noch hier so ja, der, der infizierte war im ADAC, ja, jetzt müssen wir alle ADAC-Mitglieder auch Unquarantäne stellen.
Na ja.
Okay, dann hat er natürlich auf seinem Kontakttagebuch weiter rumgeritten. Das ist so ein Feature, was wohl ist äh in den nächsten Monaten auch irgendwann mal in die Corona-Warn-App schaffen soll. Da gab's ja ein paar Ankündigungen,
blicken wir vielleicht später nochmal drauf. Ja, also.
Bin nur teilweise äh Held rausgegangen, also es war eine gute Zusammenfassung, wie er das so sieht. Du kannte ich das zumindest schon weitgehend äh am dringlichsten fand ich eigentlich seinen Hinweis einerseits auf diese Triageproblematik, also die Überlastung
Krankenhäuser, weil er ja auch schon meinte, dass er auch schon in der Charité irgendwie dreiviertel der Betten jetzt irgendwie ähm,
nächst belegt sein äh werden, ne? Und äh und die große Hoffnung natürlich, dass äh die Antigen-Schnelltests äh die Situation entschärfen können.
Ja, wobei.
Darf, ganz interessant war, war gut die Anti-Genschelltest sind halt nicht so empfindlich, aber die Empfindlichkeit äh.
Liegt halt ungefähr auch bei dem, äh was so, wo du als infektiös gilt. Das heißt, wenn du einen PCR-Test machst, äh ist der auch positiv.
Lange nachdem du eigentlich gar nicht mehr ansteckend bist.
Während halt diese schnellen Tests eher damit korresponieren, dass du sagen kannst, okay äh die können negativ ausfallen,
relativ früh, wenn halt die Viruskonzentration zurückgeht und natürlich sind die auch wesentlich empfindlicher gegenüber einer schlechten Probenentnahme
So, dann können die halt auch schief gehen, aber,
Du hast in einer Viertelstunde das Ergebnis und kannst halt damit dann so andere Szenarien machen, wie dass jeder, der in ein Altersheim kommt oder jeder, der im Krankenhaus aufgenommen wird oder so, erstmal so einen Schnelltest
kriegt, um da eine zusätzliche Sicherheitsebene zu schaffen. Und ja.
Das kann ich mir halt ganz gut vorstellen. So, dass man damit einen Schritt weiterkommt. Was mir so ein bisschen.
Fehlt so in dem ganzen,
Dingen noch ist, wie man's denn jetzt hinkriegen will, dass wir nicht ständig wieder neue Logdowns brauchen, weil.
Eigentlich diese Strategie, für die wir uns entschieden hatten mit dem ersten Logdown, die ja auch als äh äh Hammer and Dance bezeichnet wurde, war ja, der auch, man packt einmal den Hammer aus,
bringt die Zahlen runter, auf einem Niveau, wo äh sie mit Tracking und Tracing und gezielter Isolation
gemanaged äh werden können und dann.
Der Anmerkung, Korrektur, man haut nicht da richtig drauf, sondern man haut überall drauf, weil man gar nicht weiß, worum man eigentlich drauf hauen soll
ja? Deswegen der Hammer, einfach mal erstmal alles plattmachen, äh alles schließen, so wie wir es auch erlebt haben und wir wissen, okay, wir haben auch vieles geschlossen, was vielleicht jetzt nicht unbedingt hätte.
Geschlossen werden müssen, um einen Unterschied zu machen, aber man wusste es ja nicht, ne? Und danach kommt halt der Dance, der Tanz. Und in dem Tanz haben wir uns jetzt so ein bisschen verstolpert.
Ja im Tanz sind wir irgendwie, weiß nicht. Äh der fand halt am Rand von einem Abgrund statt und da sind wir jetzt einfach
immer näher an den Abgrund ran und ja sind da jetzt eigentlich jetzt irgendwie nicht mehr am Tanzen, sondern sind da jetzt gerade wieder im freien Fall.
Kurz gleich so ein krasses Bild. Ist ein Tanz am Vulkan, ja.
Mhm. Und äh ja, aber das ist, das war nicht eigentlich nicht die Strategie.
So, ja, das war nicht die Idee äh so und die Frage ist halt jetzt natürlich wie, was hat die Bundesregierung jetzt für Ideen, wie wir.
Dass sie jetzt diesmal besser hinkriegen, wie wir dafür sorgen,
dass dieser Lokdown jetzt der letzte ist und für den Tanz halt äh diesmal ja auf der Tanzfläche bleiben. So und ich meine, ich.
Das haben wir auch genug häufig genug hier äh in der Sendung äh besprochen, dass mir unerklärlich war, wieso eigentlich,
einen.
RWT über eins toleriert ist, wieso das nicht äh äh grundsätzlich, wenn man nicht sagt, okay, wenn die Zahlen steigen.
Klar, wenn die Zahlen klein sind, kann man sich nicht am RWT alleine äh mehr orientieren, äh aber im Prinzip äh kann man sich immer noch am Wochenschnitt äh orientieren und wenn man jetzt sagt, oder am meinetwegen auch am Monatsschnitt.
Aber sagt okay in einem Monat waren die Zahlen jetzt deutlich höher als im Vormonat so,
dann muss man agieren, da kann man nicht einfach sagen, oha, mal gucken, warten wir nochmal einen Monat oder warten wir nochmal zwei Monate oder drei Monate, so wie wir das gemacht haben? Nee.
Dann hat man eigentlich den, den Salat, das ist halt nicht Tanzen, so immer weiter näher an den Abgrund äh so, das waren jetzt nicht der der Tanz eigentlich.
Sondern ja und wie das passieren soll äh ist halt unklar und hm.
So ein bisschen fehlen mir auch vielleicht etwas Mutigere Ansätze so. Ich habe das Gefühl, man ist jetzt wieder in so einer Spur drin und äh ist da nicht so innovativ.
Wie ähm ja ähm beispielsweise immer wieder das Beispiel mit den Chinesen oder jetzt äh auch Beispiel Slowakei, die die Bevölkerung mit Antigenschelltests getestet haben.
So wo man sie auch fragt, okay, warum testen wir jetzt nicht beispielsweise mit Antigenschnelltests äh die komplette Bevölkerung durch,
meinetwegen von Norden nach Süden oder wie auch immer und ja,
versuchen halt so das Ganze zum Stillstand zu bringen, indem wir einfach äh mit Hilfe von Tests diejenigen identifizieren, die gerade infiziert sind,
So. Eigentlich eine naheliegende Kiste, klar, mit PCR geht das nicht,
aber äh so ich meine,
wenn die Chinesen oder jetzt äh in in der Sowakei wurden halt zweieinhalb Millionen Leute getestet, so da fragt man sich, okay, wenn die Slowakei jetzt.
Zweieinhalb Millionen Leute getestet, hat bereits warum ist jetzt nicht vorstellbar, dass wir
Ich sag mal, vielleicht im Dezember oder im Januar
dass wir halt einen nationalen Vorrat an Tests anlegen und dann halt gezielt innerhalb von zwei Wochen zweimal die komplette Bevölkerung durchtesten und,
ja und so halt deutlichen Schritt machen.
Hört mal ein paar Anmerkungen zu diesen antigen Schnelltest, der da in ähm der Slowakei durchgeführt wurde, also wie du schon gesagt hast, sie haben zwei Komma fünf Millionen Leute getestet. Davon waren fünfundzwanzigtausend positiv.
Also ein äh nee nicht ein Prozent, sondern doch ein Prozent.
Und ähm das und zwar das bedeutet, ne, weil Anti, also vielleicht mal kurz Antigen äh Test, also Antigen heißen die Dinger ja deshalb äh als Antigen.
Bezeichnet man die ähm quasi die Kennung dieser.
Proteine der Viren, wie sie sich nach außen zeigen, ja? Also,
Jeder hat ja schon so dieses allgemeine Bild des Virus gesehen, wo dann so diese kleinen Zipfelchen überall dranhängen. Das sind ja diese sogenannten Spike-Proteine. Also die
Proteine, die halt wie so kleine Spitzen dann in diese Zellen eintreten und die so den eigentlichen Anknüpfungspunkt darstellen und,
ist halt einerseits ist es die Angriffsfläche, aber es ist halt dann eben auch umgekehrt, die Angriffsfläche für die Antikörper. Die Antikörper erkennen halt.
Diese Proteine eben an bestimmten Teilabschnitten.
Und das sind die Adegener. Und diese Schnelltests sind halt dafür gemacht quasi diesen Virus unmittelbar zu erkennen. Also von außen am Protein.
Schwangerschaftstest. Äh also.
Dann ein Schwangerschaftstest ist, wie du ihn, wie du ihn dann abliest, ja? Das ist ja nochmal eine andere Sache, aber die eigentliche Funktionsweise ist halt, du hast halt äh quasi.
Innerhalb dieses Tests quasi so künstliche Antikörper, die eben den ähm den Virus als Seuchen erkennen. Ja, also die erkennen wirklich die Präsenz des Virus selber.
Nicht etwa wie wir das jetzt bei diesem PCR-Tests haben die RNA, die da drin ist.
Und deswegen brauchst du halt große Mengen. Das bedeutet wiederum auch.
Die Artigen Test testen halt dann positiv, wenn du eben auch infektiös bist und nicht wie du schon richtig gesagt hast, irgendwie den Virus in sich tragen, auch wenn man nicht mehr mehr infektiös ist. Ein Prozent.
Bei zwei Komma fünf Millionen Leuten ein Prozent, die ich weiß jetzt nicht über welchen Zeitraum das lief, paar Tage, ja.
Ähm also die in diesem Zeitraum ähm wirklich infektiös waren. Das ist eine extrem.
Wie ich finde und äh die hast du jetzt auch alle rausgenommen innerhalb dieser kurzen Zeit.
Ja, also es ist eine eine riesige Verbreitungslast, die da quasi einfach aus dem System
rausgenommen wird und diese Tests ist ja auch relativ günstig, ne? Klar, du hast natürlich bei so einer Abwicklung, hast du natürlich nochmal eine megalogistik am Start und du musst äh sehr viel Personal auch äh mitbringen, du musst ja irgendwie auch an die Leute irgendwie rankorben und so weiter und so weiter
Die haben natürlich dann auch harte Maßnahmen gehabt, also wer sich nicht testen lassen wollte, muss es stattdessen zehn Tage in Quarantäne gehen,
oder Strafe zahlen, wobei mir jetzt nicht ganz klar ist, wann dieses Oder greift, also.
Ja, wahrscheinlich bei, ist.
Wenn sie das nicht wo.
Quarantänebruch.
Genau oder wenn sie halt sagen so, nee, Quarantäne dich auch nicht und dann sagen die, ja okay, dann musst du halt jetzt die Strafe zahlen. Und nicht zu knapp, so irgendwie sowas wie tausend, tausendfünfhundert Euro, tausendsechshundertfünfzig Euro
So, ist äh so eine Maßnahme, die jetzt auch nicht sonderlich populär wäre, aber äh na ja, hilft aber, ne.
Wobei ich mir jetzt die Zahlen in der Slowakei gar nicht angeschaut habe aktuell.
Das war jetzt dann nochmal nachgucken, ob das schon irgendwelche äh Auswirkungen gezeigt hat.
Ja, kann man ja gerade mal schnell Slowakei sagtest du.
Also wir haben sehr viel stärkeren Ausbruch gehabt als wir. Doppelt so.
Mhm. Aber seit ja Ende.
Oktober gibt es dort der Schnitt auch äh also ist der Anstieg einen deutlichen Knick äh äh gemacht und steigt jetzt auch eher langsam an.
Ja, was ich nicht ganz genau schaue, ob das hier in dem Bericht genannt wird. Ähm Meldung ist vom dreißigsten Oktober und das war ein dreiwöchiger.
Ablauf.
Alle Leute ab dem äh Alter von zehn Jahren getestet. Haben sie mit der Armee zusammen gemacht.
Okay, aber auf jeden Fall.
Sieht es so aus als hätten sie ungefähr dann ja das Ganze ist fast zeitgleich so mit Tschechien ist dort dann auch.
Zum Stillstand gekommen, wäre jetzt auch interessant, mal zu sehen,
Ja, wann die irgendwie welche anderen Maßnahmen die einzige Maßnahme war, aber ja auf jeden Fall ähm man.
Man muss dazu noch sagen, zwei Komma fünf Millionen Leute, das ist ungefähr vierzig Prozent der Bevölkerung. Und wenn du sagst, null bis neun fällt raus, dann ist es irgendwie locker die Hälfte der Bevölkerung.
Gut, das wird man sehen, dass auch da müssen glaube ich diese Maßnahmen jetzt äh erst noch die Ergebnisse zeigen.
Ja. Aber ich sage mal, grundsätzlich sind sich ja eigentlich alle einig, dass viel testen hilft viel, so,
aber ähm dass diese Strategie sehe ich gerade noch nicht so richtig bei uns äh mit Werf äh äh verfolgt. So, da ist man eher so.
Wir machen das erstmal so wie beim letzten Mal.
Ja, wir gucken mal. Wir wir gucken mal, was passiert. So und
Ja, das kann gut gehen. So, aber ich finde das eigentlich ein bisschen fahrlässig, ehrlich gesagt, sich darauf zu verlassen ähm.
Dass das gut geht so,
und wie man's dreht oder wendet und ob jetzt die Schulen äh jetzt Treiber von Infektionen sind oder nicht. Ähm ja,
ein Stück weit.
Erhöhen sie, also tragen sie zur Verbreitung bei, das kann mir keiner sagen, dass die Schüler oder Schulen jetzt keine Rolle spielen, ja.
So.
Weil äh und insbesondere natürlich in dem Moment, wo du den Virus andere Verbreitungsmöglichkeiten nimmst äh so kann's halt gut sein, dass er sich dann,
andere Wege sucht, ja oder die Wege, äh die dann bleiben, dann äh halt mehr Rolle spielen. Ehrlich gesagt, sondern auch dazu sagen, okay,
Zahlen geben das im Moment noch nicht her, sieht nicht so aus, als wenn die Schulen jetzt.
Da signifikant wären, aber schauen wir mal. Am Ende wird abgerechnet.
Kommen wir nochmal zu ein paar kleineren Sachen, vielleicht auch nochmal eine Information ähm hier für Berliner.
Es gibt nämlich jetzt äh auch so ein Testzentrum am BER. Ich bin mir nicht ganz so sicher, ob's auch schon eins an TXL gab. Mich hat diese Information jetzt erst erreicht, habe da etwas widersprüchliche Informationen bekommen. Auf jeden Fall gibt's das,
Das heißt, wer jetzt wirklich in der Situation ist, sich schnell testen lassen zu wollen.
Äh schnell es in von Promentnahme, bis man zum Ergebnis kommt in unter vierundzwanzig Stunden, dann kann man einfach zum BER fahren.
Am besten seinen Account.
Ich kann das mal alles verlinken und dann fährt man da halt hin und wenn man vor vierzehn Uhr seine Probe abgegeben hat.
Dann geht die halt noch am Abend äh zum Labor und äh man kriegt dann bis elf Uhr auch ein Ergebnis. Und das bedeutet, äh dass man eben so innerhalb von.
Einundzwanzig Stunden sogar äh Nachweis bekommt.
Und kostet auch nicht äh mehr als wenn man jetzt zum also kostet sogar weniger als wenn man jetzt zum Arzt geht, sagt das halt irgendwie sechzig Euro und.
Zehn Euro oder neun Euro extra, wenn du auch noch dein wenn du sozusagen noch eine eine,
Identitätsfeststellung haben willst, also das sozusagen auch Briefkrist, wo draufsteht, hier, Herr Pappelmeyer, den haben wir getestet, der, der darf jetzt hier irgendwo rein oder raus.
Dann kann man das da irgendwie machen. Das ist halt die selbe Firma, die jetzt schon auch in Frankfurt einen anderen Flughäfen, Hamburg, glaube ich, auch ähm entsprechende Testcenter eingerichtet hat, das äh bindet sich natürlich da vor allem an Flugreisende
aber kann im Prinzip von jedem benutzt werden, ist auch dasselbe wie diese äh Testboxen, die man sich halt einfach auf Amazon klicken kann.
Ich habe da mal so ein paar vorrätig und dann kann man halt irgendwie sagen, ja, hier hol mal ab und dann hat man einen Tag später das Ergebnis. Also da muss man.
Kommt man nicht auf unter vierundzwanzig Stunden, aber man kommt auf jeden Fall, wenn man's richtig timt auf äh unter achtundvierzig Stunden. Das ist auch schon mal ganz gut.
Dann hat der Karl Lauterbach ähm noch ein bisschen was getwittert, das fand ich ganz interessant und zwar Long Covet.
Ähm ich zu verwechseln mit Sirokovit, also Longkovet ist jetzt sozusagen ähm betrifft die Krankheit selber.
Da wird eben einfach nochmal in so einem, so einer Studie aufgearbeitet, was äh denn so die Krankheit denn alles so bewirken kann. Ich meine, dass man davon sterben kann, das haben wir jetzt schon alle gehört, aber es gibt eben auch Probleme mit,
lan.
Andauernden Gesundheitspolitik. Also selbst wenn einen das nicht umbringen kann, einem halt trotzdem Schaden. Und ich dachte, es wäre vielleicht nochmal ganz wertvoll, das hier auch nochmal zu erwähnen, zumal es eben äh jetzt.
Probleme sind, die eben auch jüngere mit leichterer Krankheit betrifft. Nicht alle, ne? Viele gehen da auch durch und merken gar nichts, manche sind ein bisschen krank und sind danach
wunderbar drauf, aber es gibt wohl offensichtlich eine ganze Menge Berichte, die auch von anderen Verläufen ähm berichten und da kommt dann hier so Symptome, Gedächtnisprobleme.
Hirnnebel, Greenfork, noch nie gehört, Herzrasen, Bluthochdruck, Luftnotbelastungsherzrasen, Kurzatmigkeit beim schnellen Gehen, Herzstolpern, chronischer Erschöpfung. Das äh klingt schon mal nicht so gut,
ja das trifft wohl auch Leute, die auch bei besser sportlicher Gesundheit sind.
Ciao. Wollte ich noch mal erwähnen.
Ja, ich meine, das hatten wir auch äh schon ganz am Anfang. Ich glaube, schon im März oder April äh hatten wir das ja auch tauchten ja erste Berichte,
auf so die Frage ist natürlich und da wir halt auch die.
Zu sehen, äh wie denn die Studien äh aussehen eigentlich wäre ganz interessant, also wie äh,
wie viele Leute jetzt tatsächlich davon betroffen sind. Das ist so der Punkt. Ich habe.
Keinen Zweifel dass ja es solche Fälle gibt, dass es äh schwierige äh Komplikationen gibt.
Und ähm,
weil gut, dass es jetzt auch nichts Neues, dass jede Virusinfektion den Körper schädigt, ja? Also,
klar, sagt immer hier, okay, Immunsystem muss auch irgendwie arbeiten, aber in dem Moment, wo das Immunsystem, also wo man so richtig
hat und ja das das führt zu irgendwie toten Zellen und das führt zu,
Ja ähm nicht mehr Gesundheit, ja? Wenn.
Du von der Virusinfektion äh äh geheim gesucht wirst und ähm ja insofern.
Ja denke ich ja, ich wüsste nur gerne, wie viel Prozent oder Promille äh sind denn jetzt von Lonkowit eigentlich betroffen? Und äh das könnte man vielleicht für die nächste Sendung nochmal versuch.
Also die Deal von ihm zitierte Studie hat viertausend neunzehn Patienten untersucht und davon.
Äh haben zehn Prozent im Alter von achtzehn bis neunundvierzig noch Symptome bis zu vier Wochen danach gehabt.
Viereinhalb Prozent ähm mehr als acht Wochen und zwei Komma drei Prozent mehr als zwölf Wochen.
Okay, ja das ist dann.
Eine andere Studie meint fünfundzwanzig Prozent hätten äh mindestens ein Symptom noch nach neunzig Tagen gehabt.
Ja, das ist das ist schon unangenehm. Also dass ich finde, das sind.
Vergleichsweise hohe Zahlen positiv stimmt natürlich, dass offensichtlich.
Das dann schon, also je länger äh umso weniger, also das ist schon grundsätzlich man die Hoffnung hat, dass die Symptome auch wieder verschwinden so, aber ja.
Ja Rot und ich meine Symptome, die du spürst und Einschränkungen, die dein Körper vielleicht dadurch erleidet, die dann langfristig irgendwann auch nochmal.
Ja Krankheitsverschärfend oder vielleicht auch lebensgefährlich eingreifen, will ich jetzt nicht ausstehen. Ich will's das hier jetzt auch nicht hochkochen und wie gefährlich das doch ist, nur mal eine andere Perspektive. Ich hatte nun auch schon.
Mal Krankheiten in meinem Leben. Und ich würde sagen, ich bin wahrscheinlich im Schnitt,
noch relativ gut davon gekommen, weil ich eigentlich noch nie so richtig brutal lange krank war, dass ich weiß ich mal so ein halbes Jahr krank war oder so mal abgesehen von.
Den Arm oder sowas. Das ist bei manchen Leuten so, aber es ist jetzt auch nicht unbedingt so normal, sondern man kennt Krankheit als
Also wenn's dich mal so richtig erwischt, dann hast du mal so eine grippalen Infarkt, ja irgendwie eine eine fette Erkältung und dann liegst du mal so zwei Wochen platt da und dann brauchst du ein paar Tage, bis dich wieder erholst, aber dann bist du halt auch irgendwann wieder da,
So, dann ist die Krankheit vorbei. So und dann geht's weiter, so wie es vorher weiterging. Aber so eine Krankheit, die ich bekommen habe, wo ich dann noch drei Monate lang dran rumzita oder die immer wieder so aufflammt oder so, das ist schon wirklich.
Unangenehme Art und Weise von Krankhei.
Ja, gib mir auch so, ich hatte mal also die schlimmste, den schlimmsten Infekt, wo ich dachte, es wäre eine Grippe, aber war
irgendwas wirklich komisches, einen auch einen viraler Infekt, aber anders als ich den
sonst erlebt hatte mit, glaube ich, schon mal erzählt mit Gehörverlust so, das war ein bisschen Spooky
und das hat sich auch irgendwie über sechs Wochen hingezogen, so bis das alles weg war. Das war aber noch,
deutlich vor, Kovit neunzehn, insofern.
Glaub ich jetzt nicht aber ja sagen auch neurologische Symptome ähm wie eben,
Geruchsverlust treten oder Geschmacksverlust treten halt auch bei anderen Viren durchaus auf.
Aber wohl nicht in der Häufung und auf jeden Fall ein weiterer Grund äh aufzupassen und das nicht haben zu wollen, weil.
Und das hört man auch immer wieder von Leuten, äh wo es dann ausgebrochen ist, die Symptome haben, äh dass das alles andere als spaßig äh.
Das habe ich auch gehört. Gut äh ich würde sagen, da machen wir mal für diese Woche äh Schluss und gucken dann mal, wie sich das jetzt so alles entwickelt. Wir gehen wie gesagt davon aus, ähm.
Wird noch ein bisschen dauern, bis besser wird. Also werden wir uns noch der einen oder anderen Hirbsbotschaft wahrscheinlich anfreunden müssen.
Ich kann meinen vielleicht noch eine Sache bisschen anekdotisch halt über Tschechien, weil ja meine Eltern.
Sind halt, nachdem sie den Sommer dort verbracht haben, ähm,
so wieder nach Berlin zurückgekommen und ja, meine Mutter war besonders glücklich darüber, äh dass sie da endlich weg ist, weil sie meinte dort auf dem Dorf, wo ja
ich sage mal in der Gegend ein paar hundert Leute leben und wo man
eigentlich denken müsste, okay, da hat man jetzt genug Platz, um Abstand äh zu halten. Geringe Bevölkerungsdichte so äh da, die Mühler sind sie einigermaßen sicher, selbst wenn die Zahlen alles anziehen
aber dann äh äh ja zählte mir meine Mutter, sie sei halt fast wahnsinnig geworden in den letzten Wochen. Erstens.
Weltuntergangsfernsehen natürlich äh so, also auf allen Programmen war nichts anderes als Kovit und Korona und äh wie das jetzt abgeht und dann aber.
Ist es so, ich meine, jeder kennt,
Aber irgendjemanden, der dann gerade jetzt erkrankt ist, so und dann fahren aber ja fährt die ganze Familie irgendwie auch so ins Nachbardorf zur.
Tante und äh obwohl dann,
der Freund von der einen Enkelin gerade äh Kurve hat und äh irgendwie in der Schule von der anderen äh vom vom anderen Enkel gerade der beste Freund
irgendwie an Kowit erkrankt sind, aber man fährt halt dann äh äh trotzdem so ganze Familie und verbringt das Wochenende dann, ja,
bei Oma auf dem Land, die dann natürlich nichts anderes zu tun hat äh so als dann ähm alle ihre Freunden und Bekannten abzuklappern und äh.
Zu erzählen, was denn alles so Neues passiert ist und so und jeden zweiten Tag dann vorbeikommt, dann die Nachbarin ausm Dorf.
Die dann rumläuft von Tür zu Tür, ohne Maske, um zu erzählen, dass sie gerade aufgefordert ist, sich testen zu lassen, weil ihre Tochter, die bei ihr lebt, einen positiven Test hatte, ja.
Oh.
So ähm dann irgendwie meine.
Kumpels, die ich da von früher irgendwie noch kenne, äh wo ich mit denen teilweise aufgewachsen bin, die treffen sich dann erstmal in der Dorfkneipe, um dann
ja auf 'nen Freund anzustoßen, der jüngst verstorben ist so
war auch infiziert, aber wer sowieso an Krebs gestorben, insofern äh äh ja,
alles, also der ist jetzt sozusagen aus deren Sicht mit Covit gestorben und nicht an äh Covit und dann kann man sich halt auch einfach in einer Kneipe treffen und das Ganze erstmal begießen. Wie gesagt, alles in einer Zeit, wo Tschechien schon Institzen über,
irgendwie siebenhundert, achthundert hat dieses Vierfache von dem, äh, was was wir hier haben, ja.
Und ich hatte das auch getwittert vor zwei Tagen und dann äh habe ich halt gefragt, wie heißt das denn hier eigentlich aus eurer Erfahrung auch so.
Und das Feedback war sagen gemischt, also es gab Leute, die sagten auch, dass es äh auf deutschen Dörfern läuft das genauso ab
und während andere sagt, ne bei ihnen geht's einigermaßen geordnet und gesittet zu, andere sagten das ist in manchen Städten genauso, das ist jetzt gar keine äh Stadtland oder Dorfgeschichte und,
mein dem liegt halt all dem liegt halt glaube ich dieses psychologische Ding zu Grunde, dass ähm,
man bei Leuten, die man kennt oder mit denen man verwandt sind, man nicht äh,
glaubt, dass die jetzt infiziert sein. Man will den nicht unterstellen und ja ähm und man will jetzt auch nicht sagen, sich dann körperliche Nähe oder so versagen äh,
Ja und.
So verbreitet sich der ganze.
So genau und so verbreitet sich das Ganze und,
wenn allen Altersgruppen oft so offenbar. Also es gibt so Leute. Also aber nicht alle sind so, sondern das das scheint halt
Auch regional, sehr, sehr unterschiedlich zu sein, wie äh sehr die Leute Acht geben oder auch nicht und äh ja
Und in Tschechien war dann vielfach von Kontaktreduzierung nicht so richtig. Die falls nicht im privaten Umfeld. Ja.
Ja, ich meine, äh, es gibt ja auch eine schöne Studie aus Stanford, die man untersucht hat, ähm wie viele Leute sich denn bei diesen ganzen äh maskenlosen Rallyes von Donald Trump jetzt hier zur zur Wahl angesteckt haben und wie viel davon gestorben sind und sie haben so eine Zahl rausgebracht von dreißigtausend Fällen und siebenhundert.
Toten? Einfach nur weil es so Donald Trump mal live sehen wolltest. Großartig, oder?
Am Ende fehlen ihm noch siebenhundert Stimmen zum Wahlsieg.
Würde ich aber da mache ich dann aber auch nochmal eine Flasche auf. Oh Man.
Ja, ja das Ganze zieht sich halt quälend dahin, aber das war ja auch absehbar. Äh aber ja.
Gut, dass es sich über die Wahl äh reden, sondern wir machen jetzt hier äh mal die Kiste äh zu. Zwei Sachen habe ich noch ähm für euch,
einerseits wollte ich mal darauf hinweisen, weil ich das nämlich immer vergesse, ihr könnt uns folgen für diesen Podcast auf ME Unterstrich UKW,
so dass es so in der Mittebene so üblich, jeder Podcast hat so seinen eigenen Twitter-Account, wo dann jede Sendung auch entsprechend rausgeschrieben wird, wo er aber auch ein bisschen Kommentare äh äh und Hinweise geben könnt.
Das könnt ihr mal machen oder ihr folgt gleich Edmeterebene, da kriegt ihr das sozusagen auch für alle Podcaster Meterebene und dann habe ich noch eine zweite äh bitte, ich muss nämlich mein Spendenkonto umstellen.
Und ja das ist erforderlich, weil mir da so etwas höhere Kontogebühren auf einmal angedroht werden, die ich zu nicht tragen kann und
da nochmal alles auf diesen Daueraufträgen und doch vergleichweise geringen Beträgen äh besteht. Da kann ich mir dann nicht noch so äh größere Fleischstückchen irgendwie,
mit überzogenen Kontogebühren rausreißen lassen. Von daher, wenn ihr einen Dauerauftrag habt für die Mieterebene,
schaut nochmal kurz in die Shownotes, da ist ein Link beziehungsweise auf der Spendenseite der Mieterebene ist eine neue Kundennummer und wenn ihr den Dauerauftrag entsprechend ändern könntet, dann,
wehre ich euch sehr dankbar. Gut, aber das war's dann schon. Ich würde sagen, wir sagen jetzt tschüss Pavel, oder?
Tschüss bis äh sehr wahrscheinlich nächste Woche.
Genau und dann gibt's wieder neue Zahlen und neuen Tratsch.